so the website io9 which is it's a very
cool website they did something the 7
global apocalypse scenarios that might
happen and we've got a couple for you
we're gonna show you three quick ones
and then i'm gonna sum up the rest so
they think one that is likely is a
pandemic and a pandemic disease love
city life and half our population lives
in cities if the disease is virulent
enough humanity could be wiped out in a
matter of months so this is sort of like
the movie contagion which I really loved
pandemic crop diseases can be just as
brilliant as animal diseases because
many farmers by identical strains of
staple crops from Monsanto and other
corporations all their crops would be
vulnerable to the same infectious
diseases so let's look at two more real
quick bolide impact a bolide is a really
large chunk of matter from space off and
on fire that can form a large crater
when it smashes into a planet I think
the dinosaurs might know something about
this often geologists will describe the
event that wiped out the dinosaurs as a
bolide impact there you go and one more
large igneous provinces a volcano that
doesn't explode instead a huge crack
opens in the Earth's crust and lava
bubbles out losing across the landscape
releasing tons of toxic gases and ash an
igneous province can whose lava for
centuries over time that fills the
atmosphere with poisons and wrecks the
environment and we've got a couple more
I'm gonna put them on hold out of those
three do you have a favorite which way
do you people going down those three
I've learned you're a real fatalist
today so you must have one of those I
don't know well you know maybe cuz cause
you said it first but pandemic sounds
really viable because I mean I see these
things getting worse and worse and worse
and we're tracing here for them with
different vaccines and things aren't
working I think we want to root for the
in the meteor impact right it's the
easiest way to go it's the quickest way
to go the virus seems like maybe it's a
possibility but it's a bad way to go
right not again but I'd like to go fast
yeah you want to be actually hit by the
meteor not sure I'm not at a wave to
come shopping and go what
at Walgreens yeah yeah yeah well I agree
in that sense like the pandemic do you
guys see the movie can't a Canadian
which I want to say it on parents it was
great but right that sort of slow
creeping that seemed like scary although
you know they would know we'd have a
couple weeks probably of knowing that a
meteor was going to hit which can you
imagine all oh we didn't know that one
in Russia when that one in Russia came
by we dad no advance warning on that one
but yeah maybe we'll have a we can send
what is it Bruce Willis and Ben Affleck
oh there to blow another maybe only have
been a so come back just another
terrible Michael Bay movie if you wanted
my thoughts on transformers for by the
way I posted a video about that look at
the other options that they gave us
options the other way as we can possibly
die climate change okay Brent I think
you're gonna have something on this one
over the next century or more changes
will wreck our crops faster than a
pandemic radiation disaster atomic war
nearby gamma-ray bursts so I guess this
has something to do with the Hulk or a
blast of highly radioactive particles
streaming out of an exploding star
invasive species moving plants and
animals around the planet where they
have no natural predators and black
swan' a sudden improbable development
that changes everything you got it got
any favor to these they're all scary and
they all seem possible viability of them
is horrifying
climate change I mean climate change and
we're gonna and you know we've already
seen the effects of what's happened when
people don't have access to clean water
and there's or fresh water and there's
you know some will argue that what's
happening in Syria as a result of this
and we're gonna see the next Wars of
course be fought over water I'm on my
way next week to Bangladesh which is you
know there's millions and millions of
people who are under threat of losing
where they live and where are those
people gonna go if we think that there's
an immigration problem now it's going to
be much worse when we lose a lot of the
land that people are including Los
Angeles
Florida's and a lot of trouble in New
York City there are some shelters we
have to bring LA and I'm so here it got
here
as a pandemic goes I don't know if
anybody's still the normal hard on HP
yeah yeah but I mean look what happened
there when the AIDS virus came about and
people just were dying and dying watched
each other dying and there was nothing
they could do about it
and that's just a little microcosm of
what can happen with all these viruses
yeah so that's yeah so that's actually a
perfect segue to my occupation which is
I'm your sensei master very odd which do
you fear more the ones that we can't
control or the ones that we can because
something like nuclear war I mean we we
invented nukes so we've had like we've
had our hand in some of this stuff some
of it if an asteroid comes as you know
we can try to stop it but it doesn't
something to do with something that we
did here which one do you fear what
would happen first or do you fear one
more or say about humanity like we want
to destroy yourself so we build nukes
all over the place and guess what you
build [ __ ] to use it that's pretty much
how it works all right things that you
can't control you can't control so like
why even want us over yeah the things
that it's always the things that permit
personally for me that you can control
that give me more stress yeah yeah
because I feel like oh I should be able
to do something about this what am i
doing something about this yeah yeah I
do think that the the most vile where
we're going and to see the most problems
is gonna be what happens with our
climate it is gonna be the threat of a
nuclear war and then the third one is
artificial intelligence which I think is
something that people don't aren't as
worried as they should be that they're
gonna like this over and they're gonna
turn on like hell yeah hell yeah exactly
yeah we don't know we don't know what's
gonna happen when artificial
intelligence happens which is coming up
in a few decades but you know for people
out there there are a lot of people who
are optimistic about it like Ray
Kurzweil and then there are people who
are scared about it well no wonder Ray
Kurzweil is optimistic he's gonna be
controlling the whole damn thing until
it turns on him and kills him well no
sense any kind of advances that we make
ultimately can end up destroying us I
mean you look at all the advances that
we have yeah so final thought of this
does the government think the government
has plans for any of these do they
really have contingencies for any of
these things well if you saw their
incredible response to both Katrina and
hurricane sandy I'm very prepared for
whatever's coming yeah what do you think
you think they have is there a file
somewhere you know like we don't know
everything is you alluded to not only I
I can't even sorry is there but I have
no idea nothing no I really don't know
it's like who knows I mean I can barely
handle like like all the things that we
think they're handling and then there's
also other files in the back I mean I
can't even fathom it I'm sorry that's
exactly why I'm doing this show folks
cuz we don't know everything so it's fun
to talk about it